and it's a mini match yeah playing this
guy again what's going on okay let's see
if he has improved his play in the
petrov in the meantime
probably not I shouldn't even know
searching to a different line now maybe
yeah switches to this one the immediate
Knight c3 Bishop d3 M that's possible if
you just cast a short this is going to
be very inoffensive
there should be three Queenie two long
castles is actually still interesting
the Queen to come in 27 long castles
okay yeah it's not really that is not
challenging at all maybe maybe this is
actually or really a bit annoying if you
truth it Pinder's long castles of course
is what you have to do and then white
has reasonable chances to try I mean I
think black is fine but okay if I Castle
here does t1 h7 takes takes Knight g5
you know just taking it
okay so he probably wants to do what
exactly
move the Queen maybe maybe Queen b5 that
is that could be an idea
Queen to be five okay
hmm I could have taken with the F pawn
that wouldn't have been that would have
been actually an interesting idea
okay so Queen f5 and ascending I'm happy
with the double F pawns
they control good squares I'm a
technically 2 as well so
[Music]
yep fairly equal but the game before
against me also one rather quickly from
a not much happening position okay I'm
trying to fix a couple of points of dark
squares here would be five preventing C
form it's not much but it's what you
have to do okay so Bishop f8
see five there is Luke II one yeah I
have to do this is just no way around it
Jim one of those pressing water out of
stone positions but if you if you
actually manage and you don't do it
every time I know but it's kind of fun
okay I wonder if I should do this maybe
it takes know wouldn't be unhappy about
it
interesting move
interesting more
probably good more get rid of that porn
that was some a little bit little bit
cramping is strong you know it's it was
a the porn was I think better to have
men not who came okay so he's he's not
really worried all that much that he has
a couple of points on dark squares
probably because of the space he is
correct in that assumption
okay it's got a bit of space I'm going
to go to the key to c6 and then I'm
trying to gain more space on the
queenside
funny ideas king c6 King before Bishop
c5 checkmate
threatening checkmate now that's funny
[Music]
there should be five Bishop c5 made he
spotted it it wasn't difficult
admittedly but still so okay let's go
for the space
hmm okay
I take it king c5
a three a [ __ ] deform King doesn't
quite it doesn't quite win I think I can
still keep a bit of Takei cancer keep
tension here
so before doesn't do much him and it
does not really do all that much
definitely true iam okay it's defended
it really
what's going on now okay King takes I'm
winning a pony right yeah pressing one
out of stone but you get the water at
the end okay so yeah that okay canceling
short is really not very testing
okay ahead it's very simple and equality
I think unless I do something
substantial like here it's 6:00 a.m.
Queen at five is not necessary but I
thought the pawn structure would maybe
give me a little bit more a little bit
more some additional ideas it just
probably require the whole time should
be five if I don't think it's a
substantial difference yeah it was it
was a good move what he played their
g-force believe I think that makes it
very young pretty much lose all the
winning ideas now I mean okay it's it's
something that if anybody black can try
because of the structure but it just
should never be in women the KO poorn
and name is funny if that was the first
one
yeah I think it's a draw I think it's a
draw
take taking c5 a3 of course I mean he
has to look for this but a3 and now I
didn't see him that I'm winning a form
the engine is not quite true that same
King f4 or f3 this one
I didn't see anything here that was my
problem I've got these three though okay
what is that it's not minus one it's
either window I draw what is there some
kind of wacky ending coming if the
engines mainline yeah I'm kind of kind
of irritated here check three and then
I'm winning the a pawn and probably the
Jeep or no God no idea I am probably not
a win but could be yea IKEA kept the
tension and here it's a draw yeah
b3 was securing the draw but you should
know you shouldn't do that that's just
not a good idea now you're losing I just
get to enter black wins yeah you have to
be persistent and try to post little
problems in those endings sometimes
people fall apart even if there's not
much going on at first sight thanks so
much for watching